hi everyone my name is mathias dion i'm
the game director on horizon forbidden
west
last year we revealed our ambitious new
project and since then the team has
continued to make great progress on the
development of the game
we are very excited and honored to give
you an update in this state of play
in the countdown video leading up to
this moment you have already seen
glimpses of the forbidden west
but now we have something truly special
for you almost
14 minutes of gameplay captured on
playstation 5
and you don't have to wait any gameplay
captured on playstation 5
and you don't have to wait any longer
let's get right to it
[Music]
uh
oh easy easy it's okay
you're safe now
right here
[Music]
wait what happened where's aaron
ambush ruins are crawling with raiders
they hit our camp hard we ran and they
chased us down
[Music]
aaron was away from camp scouting
i bet he's still out there
raiders got machines on their side
clawstriders
[Music]
you should go after aaron if they find
him before you do who knows what they'll
do to him
no i you're injured i have to don't
worry about me
i'll make my own way out get going
okay yeah
what are raiders doing in these ruins
i hope erin is okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
raiders riding machines
this is not good
better be careful there might be more
[Music]
yep another one
i need to get clear
that was close
[Music]
i can't shake them
maybe i can lose them in here
these guys won't give up
[Applause]
more shoes
[Music]
oh don't mind me
[Music]
the current's strong here
[Music]
i have friends okay i'm not just the
ones you slaughtered
but when they come looking for me
there's gonna be
trouble
you guys wouldn't be laughing all right
my hammer
you know get moving
[Music]
so
i gotta help errands and deal with that
tremor tusk
make it look like bandits were here then
we'll head for the old bridge and meet
up with the others
will do yeah got it this must be aaron's
camp
raiders made short work of it filthy
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome
i'm gonna take you out
[Music]
you think you can hurt me
yeah i do all right
back to the hunt
raiders said they were heading for the
old bridge
maybe i can cut them off
better get to higher ground find a way
there's the bridge
[Music]
i think i know a way to get there first
[Music]
i gotta be careful
okay
that should do it
[Music]
help's on the way aaron
[Music]
[Music]
hey boy
[Music]
hey life
aaron stay put i'll handle this
gotta keep moving
gotta slow you down
[Music]
[Music]
time to head back
so
[Music]
time to finish this
hey lord
glad to see me now you bet
ah i owe you another one
come on
but this time i have a present for you
oh i found it emily
huh what you sent me for right before
the raiders got me
you did good now
let's see where this thing will take us
you always said a storm was coming
yeah and it's almost here
[Music]
so there you have it the first gameplay
footage from horizon forbidden west
running on playstation 5.
we hope you are as excited about it as
we are
while we have you here we would like to
spotlight some of the new elements you
have just seen in our gameplay capture
and to help with that please welcome ben
mccaw narrative director on horizon
forbidden west
thanks mathis and hello to all our
viewers
horizon forbidden west is set a thousand
years in earth's future
after a global catastrophe people live
on in primitive tribes
but they're no longer the dominant
species giant
animal-like machines now roam the land
and they are extremely
dangerous the machines aren't the only
threat in the forbidden west
a strange red blight is spreading across
the land
and it won't be long before it strangles
all life
eloy our hero is the only one who can
stop the blight
but to do that she and her companions
will have to comb through the ruins of
the old world to find the technology
they need in this quest
eloy has sent her loyal friend aaron
into the remains of san francisco
to find a crucial piece of technology
aaron encounters
raiders from a rebel faction of the
tanakh tribe
they are vicious fighters but even worse
they've acquired the power
to override machines to rescue aaron
aloy winds up fighting them but first
she must cross the ruins
to reach their camp we face a lot of
obstacles as we traverse the ruins of
san francisco
to overcome them we've given ayloy some
great new tools
using the focus scanner you can
highlight spots that allow free climbing
anywhere in the open world
the pool caster speeds up climbing and
can get you quickly out of trouble
the shield wing allows you to safely
descend from great heights
or surprise enemies from above
with the diving mask you can stay
submerged as long as you like
and take your time to plan a path around
amphibious machines
or boost through strong underwater
currents
and to speed up overland travel a
variety of machines can be overridden
and used as mounts
or in combat combat in horizon for
middlewest puts a strong emphasis on
tactics and player choice
for close range combat the spear is an
excellent option
there's a range of combos that have
different uses and effects
valor surges add a unique set of special
abilities one of which can be used to
knock back nearby
enemies the spear can be charged to
create a high damage effect that can
take down even the stronger enemies
a wide array of different weapons is
quickly accessible via the weapon wheel
a slingshot with adhesive grenades to
temporarily stall machines
both with arrows that can strip armor
and expose weak spots
a powerful launcher that fires spikes
that explode on impact
smoke bombs that temporarily blind
enemies or you can pick up weapons shot
off from machines
the full game has many more unique
weapons and each of them can be upgraded
on a workbench
but more on that another time
the player will need to be smart and
creative and use all of the combat
options we have shown
to deal with a large variety of deadly
machines
sun wings in the sky gloss fighters and
tremor tusks on land
step maws in the water even the
seemingly harmless burrows that you saw
briefly swim by
they are all dangerous and even more so
when overridden by human rebels
we've only scratched the surface of the
rebel threat as aeloy will fight them in
many forms throughout the game
and to defeat them she must explore the
open world to uncover the secret behind
their power
and how that secret is related to her
quest to stop the blight
this is just one of the mysteries she'll
unravel as her journey through the
forbidden west
takes many twists and turns
it's time to wrap it up we will have
more updates close to launch and
everyone here at gorilla
can't wait for you to experience the
full game thank you for watching
playstation
you